[Musik]
ich muss ja hallo heimkinder hey hey
guten tag hallo hallo hallo wie geht's
euch ja ich bin heute schon wieder live
hi ha da kommen sie rein
ach ja ich bin heute wieder live geld
was aber machen was aber machen wir mal
nicht lockt und irgendwas online gehen
muss dass man das ist doch super
hab ich das mache ich das mach ich das
mache ich sofort
ich habe dieses lied im kopf weiß gar
nicht warum also heute möchte ich mit
euch christmas auf youtube abchecken und
man ein bisschen so reagieren auf das
was youtube deutschland so an christoph
bietet ich muss nur den slot mal an
machen
langsam modus aktivieren
45 sekunden hat mir gestern 45 sekunden
ist gut die leute sind wir denn ist
gerade im stream
ich konnte es gar nicht sehen 1000 hey
leute jetzt 1000 menschen gar kein
pressure okay also heute mit dem
bisschen reagieren auf das was auf
youtube deutschland weihnachten passiert
ich hatte eigentlich blog mäßig was
geplant ab heute schon für den block
angefangen zu drehen aber dann dachte
ich so aber ich schaffe das nicht heute
also ja ich habe halt gedreht ich grüße
euch alle leute eher langsam modus weil
bei 1000 leuten die gleichzeitig
schreiben ist halt extrem anstrengen um
das meine zu sorgen
wollt ihr weihnachtsbaum mucke was wir
wollen wir heute hören ich kenne dabei
immer die musik aussuchen weil dann kann
also die auch einfach laufen weil die
benutzer für meine videos wieso streams
hier und nicht auf twitter wo der jet
deutlich übersichtlicher ist weil ich ja
blogs auf youtube mache und wenn ein
flottes video ausfällt dann möchte ich
ja youtube eine entschuldigung geben so
also nicht entschuldigung aber halt
einfach ich will nicht einen tag
ausfallen lassen ohne dass ihr meine
schöne hack fresse zu sehen bekommt
donate button kann ich das jetzt so soll
ich tun wollte dass mein gott
was seine lieblingsorte wow
mein lieblings als zitrone
weihnachtsmusik ist schon cool es ist
block muss ich mache einfach die schöne
weihnachtsschmuck rein also so ok wiesen
die band albums albums okay ich glaube
im christmas angegeben wie findet man
die diese aber diese treppe oder dings
war geil die war so richtig entspannt
view lofi christmas beats das ist okay
wird jetzt laut
es entspannt oder hört ihr es
der livestream bleibt wahrscheinlich
online hoffe ich ich will heute auch
nicht viereinhalb stunden in einem
stream sowie gestern vier stunden
gebraucht hat um diese karte zu machen
aber es hat sich gelohnt die karte wurde
extremst gut ich hoffe dass sie morgen
schon geliefert wird ich kann mir jetzt
aber gar nicht vorstellen wir haben sie
gestern gemacht und morgen soll sie
schon geliefert sein
die müssen ja 40 karten erstmal unser
fotodruck und da muss ja aber auch 40
mal diese goldfolie drauf und dann muss
es noch in die post geschickt werden und
dann muss es zu mir kommen das sind zwei
tagen ich ja zwei nicht mehr ganze zwei
tage die sterben gerade auch
wahrscheinlich alle wegen dem christmas
oh mein gott wickeln ja danke
pauli alles klar ich finde das ist eine
mega gute idee das trinken von freddy
und mir ist gerade online gegangen und
das ding ist ich kenne ja schon mal
lauter machen das ding ist dass ich das
eigentlich abnehmen sollte das heißt ich
sollte das vorher mal anschauen ob das
okay ist weil wir halt da halt das erste
mal so richtig dran sind sowie richtig
krank
ich habe aber voll verpennt mir das
anzuschauen
also ich habe gedacht ich mach das mal
und dann habe ich es aber nicht gemacht
neuesten kitchen also okay wir geben uns
dass leute ich wurde richtig junkie ist
es schon ich würde echt richtig krank
ich ja gar kein okay musik bitte musik
lauter musik ist aus weil ich möchte
heute er heute möchte ich so ungefähr
eine stunde live stream also so bis 19
uhr live stream ist das okay für euch
ganz entspannt auf entspannter basis
die laut hält die das ich muss auf jeden
fall weitermachen
es könnte laut
geil bei der cover luna werbung da kann
ich den ton auf jeden fall
ist das gut
jo
sehr gut
alles klar okay
ok
ihm ist beschreiben wenn es zu leise
oder so ist ich bin kein alkohol ist
eine legale droge und sollte bewusst und
verantwortungsvoll genossen werden
missbrauch kann dir und den leuten in
deiner umgebung schaden zufügen
don't drink and drive die leute in
diesem video trinken in einer
kontrollierten umgebung und unter
beobachtung von nüchternen freundin
passt auf euch auf bitte nicht
nachmachen sage ich bei cockpit sieht
man ja auch nie so eine dings weil aber
auch man muss sagen bei cocktails sie
ballern sind wir ja nie so recht ran
weil wir machen ja die cocktails am ende
trinken wir von allem einen schluck und
dann sind wir halt nicht betrunken so
außer der eine trinken vielleicht ein
bier deshalb leicht angestupst aber wir
sind nie halt wirklich betrunken und da
sind wir halt wirklich betrunken
[Musik]
lautstärke passt leute
passt lautstärke ja wahrscheinlich schon
ich habe einfach keinen bock drauf voll
bildschirm wenn ich voll bildschirm
mache was ich könnte noch größer machen
ich mache mal größer weil ich habe so
einen großen pc also kinomodus aber da
muss ich kleiner machen
nun sieht man das ganze ja so sieht man
es ganz so super können wir die werbung
hier unten weg machen
nein kann man nicht schlau okay aber
wenn ich vorbild dann verdecke ich doch
mit meiner meiner fresse also dann ist
auch hier meine fresse und dann ist da
noch meine fresse die macht ausdehnung
der setzt sich auch mal aufs bild drauf
okay ich mache es einfach mal also wenn
ich voll bild machen würde
wer halt so dann verdecke ich ganz schön
viel und kann ich mich noch kleiner
machen so super mensch genau wie ging
das aber jetzt ist die hälfte
das geht nicht vorbild wenn ich mitmache
dann ist nämlich auf der seite hatte
sich also einen schlitz weg okay okay
jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt durch
durch klagen komisch abgeschlossen mit
wasserzugang hätten schon so viele über
liebe gekämpft dass alles gut das ist
alles gut dass noch niemand gemacht was
passiert jeder diese schoko sushi isst
nur zehn minuten drin bleiben wir helfen
jetzt kurz unserem kind zu treffen das
ist so lustig kelly ist immer bei drang
kitchen dabei also immer wenn getrunken
wird bei freddy im büro ist sie einfach
dabei komplett aus
das waren 13 12 die kamera
die hat laktose klima tickets spaß aber
die ist dann richtig sommer wenn ich so
was sage sie sagt dann also die ist dann
die marie die sau als ich gesagt habe
sie zwei haben du kannst nicht bei jeder
sau folge immer auftauchen es wird
langsam too much jede folge ist sie hier
ist ein gleichwohl auf ein paar
notwendig ist
hey ich freue mich sehr heute bei der
neuen verein kitchen richtig aber außer
dem video drehen auch noch für vanessa
heute als vor trinken ein bisschen
lauter bitte nur klar kein problem
drei cocktails sie weiland und da haben
wir uns so richtig schönen mit
champagner weg 85 bei null anfangen
so wenn man jetzt mal abfahrt abfahrt
wir sehen uns gleich wieder wenn die
stimmung ein wenig gehoben ist das immer
wieder wenn ich trank ich wenn jetzt
richtig richtig krank ich sitzen wir gar
nicht anschauen ich glaube deswegen habe
ich erst auch nicht zur abnahme
angeschaut weil ich wusste dass egal was
also wie das video sein wird ob da
irgendwie oder irgendeine ahnung drin
sein wird
das war eine kleine oh mein gott ist
muss ich das alles irgendwie auch noch
gleichzeitig jetzt beweglich dass ich
bewege mich so ein bisschen rum guck mal
bub war ja heute mehr auf videos
reagieren also bleibt es dann einfach so
richtig professionelle alle hier am
start sage ich das ist ja richtig geil
[Musik]
maniche war das christmas das ist ja für
mein neues denken
ich war jetzt beim veganer oh mein gott
denn friedlich sein in berlin gibt es so
ein veganer nein nein nein also 1990
liegen heißt er und da kriegt man so
ganz viele zahlen für 350 so sieht ein
salat wandten
frühlingsrollen alles mögliche ich
glaube die ganzen kosten 350 mann kannst
du dir so 314 aussuchen oder noch eine
schale reis irgendwie von euro dazu und
das ist so lecker gewesen das einzige
problem ist dass ich nicht essen können
was beim veganer essen ein bisschen
schwierig ist weil irgendwie ist alles
mit tofu also ich kriege bauschmerzen
von tofu tatsächlich ich krieg' ich weiß
nicht warum das ist so das einzige
lebensmittel was ich immer noch nicht so
überhaupt nicht vertragen können also
kannst du mal weitermachen yahaya der
zwischenzeit kommt jetzt die ware
angedreht haben ein bisschen gelaber
damit tolle comedy geguckt und ich habe
heute eine frage ja schon gehört aber
nur für mich weniger für dich weil du
musst morgen noch nach berlin fahren ja
weil ich ja ich bin schon ich bin
einfach ich höre dass euch die youtuber
sagt mahnaz tambay wir haben das blut
wir können alle wir könnten gerade im
sterben liegen und würde noch schöne
sammlung machen können und dann und dann
wieder der klassiker sind einfach nur
direkte weg zu nehmen also das ist dass
man daran
da habe ich heute ein zweiter kann den
ball letztlich von kitchen richtung
bisschen drüber
wir haben so durcheinander getrunken und
ich würde vielleicht gerne dann
einzustellen wenn ich verraten sollte
kurz vielleicht eine runde aussetzen ist
mit dem feind
bei mir würde vielleicht mal
einschreiten kommt nochmal ein cooles
böse hier nochmal also jetzt
ja das können wir uns auch alle dann mal
märkten ein cooles bis eigentlich auch
nur weil die noch nichts getrunken haben
wir unsere kosten dafür bin ich in
meiner alkohol ist böse einblendung
reinreden ich habe auch ein also kennt
eine seite von mir nicht ich hab so ein
betrunkenes also so ein anderer mensch
der in mir drin ist und wenn ich
betrunken bin kommt dieser mensch raus
ich habe ich glaube ich noch nicht den
namen verraten aber diese person hat
auch einen namen
und die kommt manchmal raus wenn ich
getrunken
[Musik]
also die person ist so ein bisschen als
sieger
als ich wirklich so viel getrunken
ich weiß auch nicht tatsächlich ob es
mehr ist bei mir aber ich fühle mich
einfach heute so schlecht sein bestes
wie so ein schlechter scherz tages das
heute ein schlechter alkohol hat weniger
so hat er die irgendwas 1 kopf ich
verstehe es aber bis jetzt noch nicht
wann ist dieser punkt also gute sind
jetzt sein das hört sich jetzt viel an
ich weiß dass man bis 0,3 glaube ich
autofahren darf und danach nicht mehr
oder ist es jetzt schon bei 0 0 aber wo
es so matt lebensgefahr bei drei oder
bei 1,5 oder bei 2 wo es eigentlich
schon dieser normale mensch kaputtgehen
würde ich jetzt mal an gisela gisela
heißt sich petra ist sie auch nicht okay
ich fahrrad durch den namen keine bereit
also den hat mir kelly gegeben als ich
mal ein kölner partie war weil ich
meistens nicht dann auch nicht erinnern
kann
ich brauche meine brille um eure
kommentare zu lesen
die personen die ihr jetzt gerade im
video seht und die er später auch noch
mehr sehen werdet ist blackout babsi
aber wegen blackout babsi 2524 ist
theoretisch ende
ich weiß nicht wie viel wir am ende
hatten aber auf jeden fall so viel dass
black ops sea cloud ii 3 promille bei 4
besteht lebensgefahr und zum alkohol und
ochs und was ist wenn man so vom
krankenwagen abgeholt wird
also wenn man also wenn man sagt so dass
jemand so wenig alkohol trinken also
einem punkt angekommen ist dass der
krankenwagen hohe combos und ihm den
magen auspumpen muss das ist dann so 1 3
promille mensch außerdem ist alkoholiker
dann schaffst es ja auch 3 promille zu
haben und nicht umzufallen 2,5 ist doch
nicht lebensgefährlich es gibt immer
wieder nachrichten gemacht aber ich war
so vorbildlich weil da gab es irgendwie
backup sie noch nicht ich war so
vorbildlich und habe ein fahrrad
geschoben und anni ist neben mir schon
so wir sind halt auch auf dem dorf
aufgewachsen deswegen sie nehmen mir so
rum getorkelt und dann kam tatsächlich
die polizei angehalten
also in kandergrund auf jeden fall
fahren fahren sollte man aber nicht wenn
man führerschein dabei dann kann er dir
abgenommen werden das ist gefährliches
halbwissen ich habe keine ahnung ob das
wirklich stimmt
glaubt mir nichts
okay man muss ja auch überlegen die mir
dazu ein getrunken und die zu groß wir
haben diesen rutschen gebrechen uns
hingesetzt musik videos angeschaut haben
uns einfach mal ein bisschen unterhalten
und das ein oder andere getränk
konsumiert jetzt mir kurz nachdem
bereits das ist er ist das ein
intensiver blick betrug 0,80 pro aktie
0,8 0,8 l hier mit freddy in der küche
und wir machen dann tun wir kriegen also
danken wir folgendermaßen allerdings man
jetzt gleich einmal das rezept mit allen
steps for falls wir einen step vergessen
sollten
wir sind in der tasche phase angekommen
shop trinken als fenster falsch machen
unterbricht sie uns sofort da ist ja
auch so böse sein wie sie sein darf und
verbessert und es dafür ist sie da das
ist das vermag die kamera muss meinen
job ich weiß heute die phase des pöbels
ist auch schon erreicht das was wir
machen bevor wir es machen weil du hast
an den tüte gerückt wurde übrigens
elektrolyse intolerant und hier ist
nicht nur schwarz
ich glaube ich weiß es das ding ist
dadurch dass ich noch nie die zutaten
für den spaghetti keine ahnung ich habe
ja nicht dass keine das ist keine
eskalation das ist keine rolle als kelly
ist wache schritte es wird die ganze
geschlafen im hintergrund weil wir
eigentlich danach noch mankartz gut
drehen wollten muss man nicht mal
geschafft haben weil als wir mit diesem
dreh fertig waren wollte ich nur noch im
club aber zum glück damit ich meinen
club gegangen
wie arrogant kann ein mensch sein ich
weiß nicht warum ich immer zu so einem
arroganten miststück werden wenn ich
getrunken und schnitt ihr wollt dann
macht ihr den
doch ein knet macht den rollierenden aus
da auch schon müde einfach blocken ist
mir leid und dann könnt ihr das hier
bezahlt wie block missstand und diese
creme darüber den teig dann müsst ihr
die zwiebeln ganz wenig wasser eine
minute in der mikrowelle dünsten
also aber ganz ehrlich wer kann sich das
denn merken das kann man sich ja nicht
mal nüchtern merken dann bist du es 500
gramm zwiebeln da müsste was irgendwie
mit kohle machen aber nicht folgen
also tennis nummer 1 zu machen jetzt
einen ingwertee
leichten und besonnen ingwertee makaay
so für einen ingwertee nimmt ihr einfach
irgendwo aus dem supermarkt in vielen
ärzten schale abschneiden das ist aber
falsch
dafür schneidet einfach den ingwer inso
stücke wirklich sagen sie müssten also
die verwirrte kameramann weil sie sonst
wegen diesen ingwer tee shot rhein zu
und woher soll ich nicht filmen wie wir
jetzt kochen warum machst du irgendwas
der schale nicht trinken
wie schneidet den nur super schön klein
das also alle ätherischen öl das sich
entfalten und das wird euch den ganzen
winter gesundheit mich auch mal wieder
klar zu kommen kannst du auch noch ihr
nicht verlieren so viel schrott noch
sorgen dass man tue ich einen teelöffel
aber wenn ich trenne die da jetzt so
sehr fremd war glaube ich nicht
betrunken ich kann mich auch nicht
erinnern dass er sich wirklich so dass
er hat getrunken aber ich was mache ich
also der hat sich jetzt ein schweizer
also bitte ich wirklich wohl hundertmal
betrunkener als dieser kaffee und dann
meist da das wasser rein du musst du
schon abgesessen hat das finde ich immer
sehr einfach
ich hatte mal ne echte chance
zwischenfall gegeben
wieso ist er immer ganz wichtig die
hände so fade bisschen waschen sie
richtig so gut wie so aussehen als ob
sie sauber wären dann mach dir einmal so
denken alle leute ist gewaschen
naja erstmal alle flüssigen zeigen was
willst du als rezept vor schweren uhr
das ist das erste ewige denen sowas muss
man nicht antworten möchte das was man
nicht einfach in dieser schale wie so
ein knet mittag ist eine der pöbel modus
ist wirklich absolut erreicht also ich
jetzt einer profi und jetzt im
nachhinein ich bin auch so sauer weil
ich habe diesen tag gemacht
[Musik]
ich mache mir nicht so ich habe genau
weiß ich sie so wir haben beide gleich
viel wasser und ein esslöffel öl
reingemacht wir haben aber beide gleich
viel abgewägt es ab gekipptes wasser
bekommen und freddys teig war ganz
anders als meine ich mal mein trocken so
und weil mein teig so 40 war habe ich
dann versuchen wir sind öl rhein zu
kippen dann will ich da noch was retten
vergessen und so begann der untergang
von meiner seele ohne draußen würdet ihr
braucht keinen stress machen
habt ihr gesehen
da fliegen noch die krümel runter das
kann doch nicht ich und ich war
betrunken ich habe das ja nicht ich habe
ja nicht eins und eins zusammenzählen
können das vielleicht trainer was falsch
gemacht hat aber
[Musik]
für mich richtig ab machte den intro für
und als männer
also irgendwie drin dann macht ihr so
ganz kompliziertes im quartier rezepte
wakefield dringend um das andere 50
prozent
so jetzt wird die einen sensibel hier
geschnitten
campion schlagen können weil ich ihre
wohnung hat immer gefilmt haben und
jedes mal dachte so also ich hab mehr
ich habe mehr auf kellys wohnungsfenster
geachtet als auf meinem sohn ist als
hättest du gegen yb und hätte so so
wenig darauf geachtet
ich habe nicht helfen den fenstern apple
einfach so abgelaufen ist nicht so viele
leute noch leicht gefallen das war es
soll die berliner luft heraus
es tut mir es tut mir einfach leid es
tut mir aber leid wie ich mich verhalten
[Musik]
ich gucke jetzt habe ich gerade halt oft
ein entschuldigungs ja ich glaub ich hab
mich beim trainer aber schon am nächsten
tag entschuldigt
ist ja auch alles für die kamera ihr
dürft das nicht so ganz zu ehren wenn du
willst dass ihr auskommen
[Musik]
die mannschaft jetzt hat die genese
gesetzt die ist schon da war deshalb zu
dem zeitpunkt habe ich also nicht
gecheckt ob sie schon da ist ob sie
sollte einfach einen eigenen youtube
kanal bekommen
guckt euch das an das ist wirklich das
ist mein erster richtiger betrunkener
auftritt auf youtube also wirklich das
ist wenn ihr mich betrunken in berlin
trifft das ist mir schon ab und zu mal
passiert dass ich von der party nach
hause gekommen und wir haben aus dem
leicht angetrunken war für mich dann
zuschauer angesprochen haben
ich bin wirklich der netteste mensch ich
bin zu züchten zuschauern weil ich da
nicht böse aber ich bin an der netteste
mensch und am nächsten tag merke ich
erst wie zu nett ich war sie was ich
meine
also definitiv zu nett zusammen wie die
glasigen augen schon also wenn drang
kitchen ist dieses mal wirklich ernst
gemeint
ganz ehrlich zwar schritt fordert dass
mir das hier zusammen mischen ja das war
der schritt erfordert dass er doch
zusammen stellen zu machen wollten ist
ja nur die hälfte oder das sei ein
vorteil haben wir keine fahrzeuge so
gesagt wer muss ein trinken wie gesagt
dankeschön eine minute jetzt glaub ich
hab gesagt eine minute er hat das
abgenommen so jetzt nimm diesen stand er
schon seit vier stunden draußen steht
die hälfte davon und den heiden nudel
fresh scheint ja nicht so viel wie eine
erlösung zu machen dann haben wir durch
heimat ist und dann zusammen sein
also das was das was ich nicht so cool
findet ist es da schon das ding drin ist
und einfach mit dem haus komplett
arbeiten muss damit umgehen dass keine
doppelschock weser
das ist einfach ganz normal tschechien
frage aber wie krank seid ihr da drüben
bitte freddy juan miguel ich hab ich
grad mal angesprochen
die sehen doch schon wie betrunken ich
bin und dann erlauben sie mir nicht das
als ein schott zu sehen
dank sogar kelly steht dort drüben und
sagt nicht kommt die hat ein bisschen
was getrunken lasst sie doch jetzt mal
dieses halbe glas trinken selbst babsi
weiß dass langsamer gut ist und nur
halbe getrunken werden mussten habe ich
ein und erwischt dass man mit milch oder
kaffee
jetzt wisst ihr was freddy zum frühstück
trinkt sind es sogar lecker anderes
[Musik]
du musst durchgreifen du bist dafür noch
immer durch gehören zudem xavi hat jetzt
einfach dass er drin gesehen und würde
also sie alles einzeln wir denken hier
soll das also ich habe schon viele
stunden ganz weit draußen rauchen dann
ist dagegen zu tun das weiß nicht warum
es so heiß also erst mal ich hab halt
gemacht weil wir sind die einzige denkst
ich habe nicht die ein plätzchen dinge
hinein ist kann es auch benutzen und
sich auf dem ding das niemand würde
jemals für so ein ding aus freut sich
weiter aus wenn die gleiche jetzt auch
einfach nur noch streiten
[Musik]
entschuldigungen an omas an dieser
stelle und auf den letzten scheiß
ausgeschwitzt hat ist kein tor
habt ihr für kelly steht da hinten und
gönnte sich erstmal ihren scheiße in
meiner sie was sagst wogegen
gut de sollte das gesetz gegen herzlich
willkommen man kann sie als protestler
kaufen artikel 13 zwar nur begrüßen
worum ging es hier muss man die bezahlen
ist du was sagst gut geht wird hingegen
diejenigen bekommen man kann sie als
protesttag auf partikel nicht nur
gekauft
michalkow hause sind trockener scheint
rein gemacht weil dann keine flüssigkeit
war genau und da war nämlich das problem
ich habe da ja also es war ja so arch
trocken wir können ja natürlich nicht
zurück in die vergangenheit schauen und
gucken ob sie mir wirklich genug wasser
gegeben hat aber freddys tag war so
richtig zudem weiß der war wie eine oma
hautnah weiter teig und mainz war wie
für planung sehr hart frau eingeleitet
werden das ist schon gut 20 minuten
fertig das kann nicht sein ich habe mehr
benutzt dieser notlage hier entdeckt
haben aktuelle entwickelt habe sehr dick
ziehen diese notlage
ich glaube ich wollte entdeckt sagen ja
dass man das anstehende ich sehe das
schon aber ich weiß es gibt nichts was
ich hätte das ding ist ab sie war halt
schon da und dann hab sie noch gemerkt
dass sie irgendwie schlechter behandelt
wurde als alle anderen haselnuss trinken
auch in deinem bohle würde das dürfen
ist es richtig entspannt ins gericht ich
weiß natürlich nichts regelung ist in
diesem sinne darf ich dann darf ich denn
mehr ganz ehrlich wird freddy betrunken
ich hab nicht den ganzen berg ich habe
dich das ganze wasser rein gemacht
welcher minute 14 22 also wenn ich und
dann meist das was mein gott
seit einer woche dachte ich dass joana
mir ist absichtlich schlechter gemacht
hat das ist ein bei für die menge das
ist nicht nur ein bisschen das ist das
ist warum ein teig so scheiße
fällt ihr der wirkt nena da wird gar
nicht wenn ja auch nicht ganz so getan
ich habe da keine lust rigi betrunken zu
sein
wer hat der hat nicht beim kochen
angefangen zu trinken wir haben schon
vorher da gesessen wir haben schon
kopfball an gedreht und dann haben wir
am tisch gesessen am tisch gesessen
musik videos geschaut und hart getrunken
mit wir betrunken werden zwar das
biertrinken der welt aber seht ihr das
tatsächlich hatte ich keinen kater ich
hatte keinen kater weil ich seit paar
wochen vor dem trinken und nach dem
trinken edu trans trinken das ist
eigentlich etwas aus der apotheke
darüber redet auch gerade jeder beim
gemisches sachs beigemischte sachs haben
sie darüber gesprochen
sido hat einem interview letztens das
gesagt es auch edu trans trinkt und ich
finde der trans gerade mega gut weil es
ist nicht wie so eine idee oder nach
trinks wenn du halt schon verkackt hass
und an das zu kopfschmerzen und versucht
nun die symptome zu senken
mit elo trans also das sind so
elektrolyten atrium blablabla damit
deckt diesen haushalt der durch damit
den alkoholkonsum gesunken ist wie wir
so beim eine scheiße ich muss echt für
kuchen und kuchen für joana backen was
macht ihr denn für den kuchen nein ich
weiss ich hoffe da guckt ihr diesen
stream ich ich könnte er ich will später
plätzchenbacken ich mache hier dann
einfach so eine kleine kiste mit
plätzchen wo so sorry steht
er hätte ja auch einfach mal in diesen
kreisen
hier gucken können ja ich war schon
betrogen aber schaut da könne man sich
richtig sehen ich drücken auf play da
sieht man richtig wie das so
[Musik]
da das ist noch ein richtig fetter also
für diese kleine schalung für diese
kleine portion ist war ja nur so in
flammen im moment machen sollten weil
das halt scheiße werde ich meine das
geschnittene ich habe sie während des
streams immer so ich kann nichts dafür
dass meine ruh trocken ist aber endlich
ist mal also endlich habe ich mal
herausgefunden woran das liegt weil ich
hab echt ich bin einfach verrückt
geworden
verstärkung für trainer auf jeden fall
ein gespenst ruhig denn mehr würde das
vorgehen
das nunmehr das ja nicht nur nachfrage
nach dem rezept ich über frage
schaut euch diesen streber schleimer an
der da irgendwie versucht sich das ja
alles über frei
sympathiepunkte versuchte sich dazu
holen was ihr am anfang gefragt habt und
und so also es geht darum ob ich also
mehr machen darf was ist dein tag
persönlich am meisten ab fakt ist dass
vanessa so krass gute kopf - macht und
jedes mal wenn wir zehn wochen ist so
irgendwas ich kriege gerade diesen statt
weil ich noch ein bisschen wasser auf
meinen teig gemacht habe gebt euch das
mache ich doch keine kekse
[Musik]
nein wir treten den ganzen schrott
vanessa der kran steht schon bereit
ich mache das ist einfach du siehst du
schwein ist er ein mann ist das ist
schon recherchiert
ich glaube da muss ich wissen will was
alles da und dann kommt dieser scheiß
drauf mitteilt bei raus und golf ready
soja ich bin war ich mir alte oma
brauche bei mir sowieso schuldig machen
jetzt schon mal unterbrechen damit nicht
zu viel sagt damit man das eine sorge
[Applaus]
ich mag ich auch richtig wenn nicht
gerade wie die wirklich angst haben
krasser trick aber ich mein ja ich
spiele gegen freddy aber mendes schmeckt
es dann doch auch schlechter wenn ich es
nicht gewürzt habe aber freddy joana hin
und sagt sie hat es nicht gewöhnt obwohl
er sieht wie betrunken ich bin
ingwer kürbissuppe ist voll lecker der
schott war zu recht ich sah einfach
schon tot aus ich sah einfach schon tot
aus ganz ehrlich die frage die sich
stellt nur für die claims was noch mal
hab ich gerade irgendwas gefragt oder so
ich verstehe nicht was gemeint ist
extreme der stream ist bald zu ende
kannst du bitte auf christmas videos
reagieren welcher stream noch weiter bis
ins weise das ist noch weiter 13 minuten
so schnell nicht also ich werde hier
nicht unterbrochen ich bin hier relativ
ein das machen wir nach oben
damit sie rief dann fahren wir auf die
see
konkurrent ist einfach nur fest
dank mir so was man sieht einfach gelebt
ist das war ich
das ist ja das ist ja alles schon
komplett so weit nichts möchte darf das
vorbereiten
aber das ist gute frage kann ich mich an
den dreh erinnern
ich weiß es passiert ist aber ich kann
mir bis heute leitet er hat gerade bist
du so durchgeschwitzt
timo hat gerade seinen ausprobiert ist
geil so ein musikspiel wo er mit so
schwertern oder ja ich denke gerade noch
auf das ist so weit weg voneinander
gästen der schlagerstar mickie du hast
was los
ich habe marcel gerade gerade monster
genannt hat schon lange
also ganz ehrlich ich raus und fertig
ist das kein mensch sagen
kein mensch in meinem leben so wirklich
ich glaube nach diesem lauf
zwiebelschneiden habe ich gesagt jetzt
erst mal anfängt entscheide anzünden
also ich sage also ich brauche nicht
versacken smoking gesehen ich habe kein
mensch aber ich habe mich daran gewöhnt
und das ist es wo ich wirklich aus
[Gelächter]
das ist meine damen und herren war
passiert
ich habe das gefühl dass ich die
kontrolle verlieren lassen und dann
einfach ins tor
darin werden dass meine leute ganz viel
besser als release muss ihn rausnehmen
jetzt rausnehmen der denn sieht schon
ganz schön wenn ich nachts mache von
joanna würde ich auch sagen er verbrennt
man es heute ist
du bist meine also ich meine filme sind
links links links links war da schon die
hand das heißt von francis kanal naja
daily hoch aber das macht doch doch aber
wenn er so ein scheiß genau
ja du bist wright pro ich drehe durch
gerne raus
[Gelächter]
ich dachte der sagt was passiert mit dem
wein und ich sicher weiß was passiert
denn mit dem bein
du musst jetzt nicht vorschlagen das
geht ja sorry es gibt ja mal forsch nein
ich gehe darum vor schneiden oder das
war am 1 du schreibst forschung auf
vorführungen geschnitten brot und
serviert mein plan gerufen nun lief
lahmte wenn man ganz in denen gemacht
wenn wir haben das ganz gut gemacht
beide ob es war nicht mein erster
flammkuchen
aber irgendwas mit laktose es hat mir
für mich ist das halt so da durchfall
und verstopfung gleichzeitig danke dir
dass du das drin gelassen hast es war
diese information war wirklich wichtig
für die ganzen leute das anschauen
werden er wird aber sagen kann dies
schon neutraler de rebuy caddy will
kelly mag mich bestimmt mehr aber sie
will mich mehr fallen sehen als freddy
deswegen gleich ist es aus und das macht
es am ende auf null und deswegen sie
neutral
das ist ein ölig ich brauche das nicht
gerade das zu gewinnen das wäre so
wichtig also optisch habe ich glaube ich
umgezogen auch das passt ja das
schreiben ja in dsds war hundertmal
besser all meine hand überhaupt nicht
geschmeckt aber hab ganz ehrlich wenn
ich das so sehe hat mich wundert mich
das jetzt überhaupt nicht ich muss aber
ich weiß dass lindens war so dünn ist
ich wäre dumm geholt ist was ich mal ist
es so ein bisschen besser möglich auf
einfach besser nicht gekürzt weil aber
wirklich shoutout an kelly an dieser
stelle weil immer wenn ich betrunken bin
hat sie also erhält sie die schnellen
schwung und sorgt dafür dass weiß ich
nicht das ähnlichen graben fall oder
dass ich keine ahnung gibt hast echt so
gut immer auf mich auf das ist
übertrieben
[Applaus]
wir haben geschmeckt mega gar nicht was
ich falsch stellt euch mal vor wir
hätten dann noch wirklich eine chance
früher gedreht es wäre eigentlich schon
ziemlich witzig geworden ist nicht so
geworden
vanessa weil du weniger wasser rhein
gekippt hast du dumme nuss aber sie sich
komplett schlecht ist es okay aber das
ist aber dass wie sie noch mit mir reden
wollen wieso so kleines kind das nicht
so ist nicht so schlecht
[Musik]
aber seht ihr ganz ehrlich wenn freddy
betrunken gewesen der suche also so so
major trank vielleicht hat er mit
gefummelt er hat ja gar nicht gefummelt
verstehen was ich meine ist da die leute
ich hatte spaß beim drehen habe die
beiden das erste mal trank ist hin und
her dass ich selbst betrunken war
ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen wie
das wie das also wie wie du das
ausgehalten hast kelly aber das hätte
ich gerne so genau das bild hätte ich
gerne als postkarte da kommt da seht ihr
das ergriff ein bisschen betrunken ist
ich glaube freddy ich glaube ich kann
mich an diese umarmung an diese
verabschiedung kann ich mich absolut
nicht erinnern aber ich glaube freddy
und ich sind uns unserem leben noch nie
so nahe gekommen
ich habe noch nie nüchtern von immer so
was gekriegt vanessa ich liebe dich ganz
schön viel frage ich die bin ich auch
ganz schön viel windows konzern gut dass
du hier bist danke dass du mir was wir
sehen uns auf jeden fall wieder
vielleicht kommen 24 verbände folge
vielleicht nicht dementsprechend hoffen
wir dass das stattfinden wird ansonsten
gibt's einen ersatz und das kommt so
oder so nach gerade ganz schön dass du
da warst weil man es halt vorbei wie er
hat mich jetzt erstmal wieder schaut mir
auf instagram auf tecdax und auf youtube
leute also wir müssen weißt du noch dass
sie miteinander aufgewachsen ist und das
auto drehen wollte ich glaube die hat
sich also wir sind nach hause gefahren
kelly hat bei mir an einer couch
geschlafen weil ich so betrunken war
damit sie mich überraschen kann und habe
mich anscheinend mit einem nachgemachten
wollte das auto drehen
[Musik]
das kann ja auch sein dass nach diesem
video ist meine karriere komplett wobei
es kooperation kommen jetzt auch nicht
mehr rein mag ich auf jeden fall schaut
es euch noch mal selber an ohne mein
gequatsche oh mein gott ist das peinlich
gewesen
könnt ihr können wir mal darüber reden
ist es ich muss auf toilette ist so wie
peinlich es ist so schlimm ich mache was
laut stadt ein bisschen weniger dann
könnt ihr mehr schreiben
wir können das sagen ganz schön lange
sind 2700 leute menschen
ich liebe euch wir machen 20 sekunden
speichern
vanessa war übervoll mit russischem
kochwasser nähe ich glaube es war eher
gin oder so aber ich habe auch wirklich
kein kater danach gehabt also ein
bisschen schon
also ein bisschen aber nicht so viel
weil die trans liebs uns denn auch
vanessa ich würde schon sagen auf so
eine seltsame 2009/10 man kann menschen
über das internet die man noch nie
kennengelernt hatte lieben art hat das
jetzt nicht gepasst es wäre richtig
krass aber ich musste es auf eins muss
ich auf jeden fall sagen
eins muss ich auf jeden fall sagen man
sollte sein handy nicht nebenbei haben
sonst vergisst man nämlich was man sagt
ich sah gut aus ich hatte eine schöne
hautfarbe also schön schön manchmal
schminke ich mich ein bisschen zu helden
sich meinen videos auch zu hell aus dann
sieht das passe sich mal mit dem hals
aber da
tarek utah zopf das oberteil habe ich
gerade von kelly abgestaubt bekommen das
war es so jetzt checken wir mal wie bibi
finden wir dann raus was so weihnachten
gerade auf youtube geht wer welcher
youtuber macht gerade so weihnachts
content ich will ja auch niemanden
hätten ich will mich ein bisschen lustig
machen aber nicht was sich mann verletzt
fühlte sich mal hin
ja das video ist als ob man die ganze
zeit das video ist als wenn man nach dem
festival die ganzen peinlichen black
baut videos entdeckt das ist wirklich
eine blackbox iq wie man das wenn man
das so zusammenschnitt über sony mal
danke das danke du bereich ist mir meine
adventszeit so so sehr auch gleich noch
mal ein weihnachtslied an wenn das der
fall ist dann leider ich mache weiter
40 macht gewitter im kopf gibt zudem die
mann der so richtig chris überhaupt
macht weihnachten alternativ macht
weihnacht konnte neues unserem fall
wieder spenden ja geldspenden könnt ihr
mir immer ich habe nur leider keinen
spendenbutton ich weiß nicht wie man den
einrichtet weil wisst ja ich bin creator
den interessiert das nicht so können wir
live stream station machen unser eigenes
update stream ok kaum leute ist
irgendwie lustig ich gucke jetzt nur den
anfang gleich los also jetzt party haben
ja sogar ein countdown ihr könnt mit mir
die hände auf antibiotika ich das heute
meine letzten tagen sagen dass live
stream live sport
[Musik]
ja also ich kann es eigentlich gar nicht
sagt ausschalten aber ich dachte wir
können ja meine theorie forschen da
sieht man gar nichts hier irgendwie ist
er hier draußen ich glaube nicht dass er
eingefroren ist der hammer
du bist eingefroren warum sollte da
nichts passt nicht so recht brav
weihnacht aber die leute jetzt erst zu
starre jetzt angezeigt haben die 88 18
uhr gestreamt auch die haben schon
gestreamt oh mein gott das peinlich oder
haben die noch nicht gestreamt heute
fast gar nichts mehr
doch die haben schon ich weiß es nicht
zudem beendete das team beendet ja das
thema beendet
ist ja nicht leib des schien es schon
vorbei jetzt wird man nicht julia und
wieso ja ich will so richtigen christmas
content wisst ihr also so klinik ging
entdeckte waiting for christmas aber
deutsches müssen deutsche machen
es gibt es hier paart deutsche dass man
am liebsten würde ich jetzt laura laura
in coco xo gucken aber shop and clean
also ich mag renz videos irgendwie nicht
mehr so ganz nehmen wir machen wir jetzt
an ihm ab wenn du kannst ja auf deine
reagieren haar an ihr glühwein getestet
mirela dekoriert ihre wohnung
barbara sofia hat auch ein paar videos
barbara da ich habe mir das angeguckt
des problems bei barbara ich finde sie
ist ein nettes mädchen aber wenn ich
jetzt auf sie reagieren würde würde sich
vielleicht verletzt fühlen weil manche
sachen bin ich nicht ich glaube ich bin
ein bisschen anders
ich finde irgendwann ihren freund ich
habe nichts gegen sie persönlich aber
ich finde so die blogs von ihrem freund
gerade weil ich jetzt auch mit meinem
freund angefangen hab vor der kamera zu
agieren und wir ich sage mal relativ wir
selbst bleiben ja hier seht ihr ich
schaue dass sie zeit ihre sachen das ist
mir immer so ein bisschen zu gysi und zu
3 und jetzt habe ich die kamera in der
hand und jetzt machen wir das und auch
mein gott da die weihnachtszeit ich bin
halt aber auch ihre zielgruppe
wahrscheinlich nicht
deswegen glaube ich gebe einfach mal
weihnachten ankommt weihnachten
40 geschenkideen für alle von sami
slimani zwei verrückte backen 24 stunden
an kekse für weihnachten becken die
wirklich 24 stunden kommt deutschlands
beste oder ist das so wieder gebacken 24
stunden und wir haben kurven vor
die 420 tonnen kekse und genehmigt hallo
verlautete ist dass krieg betclic bett
ihr glaubt das klingt ist für 20 stunden
lang gebacken wieder ich möchte glaube
dass gleichheit und über die gesagt nein
ich sage es jetzt mal ganz klar ich
mache ich sage nicht dass das zwei mal
schlechte menschen sind wir wissen es
nicht vielleicht spenden sie jede woche
drei millionen euro an kinder in afrika
und weil sie nicht helfen jeder oma über
die straße
man bewertet halt wirklich nur was man
sieht und was anscheinend von den
entschieden online gestellt wird okay
gut
juli die ich freue mich
die nicht so ich bin nicht so gut im
backen und ich weiß dass wenn ich einmal
kekse gebacken habe dann würde ich ein
aber die mama sarina ist die victoria
victoria ist die blonde sarina ist die
braunhaarige und victoria hatte man so
ein dauergrinsen im gesicht
dies richtig eigentlich heißt er nach
fünf minuten kekse backen keine lust
mehr ist nur noch ein handy aber wir
müssen ein neues video raushauen es ist
weihnachtszeit im dezember gibt das
money money money deswegen habe ich sie
aus ihrem zimmer geholt
die zweite klatsche nicht einmal deine
events ihre rolle wird zum verzieren zum
backen zu gehabt das ist aber auch
content nehmen alles mit glas von
gestern
weißt du so ein normaler mensch würde
das so einer hand halten
das ist das einzige video wo ich mich
über leute lustig machen werde weil das
ist okay aber ich weiß ganz sicher dass
ich nach einer großen darum kekse auch
lust habe auch das einzige es geht nicht
wir können keine pilze währenddessen
bestehen
keinen tag verlieren ich muss mir auch
von denen auch mal was abgucken ich
vergesse dass jedes mal zu sagen gibt
bitte jetzt mal dem livestream hier
daumen nach oben dankeschön gerade 11
uhr mittags wir starten hiermit
offiziell unseren 40 stunden gehen sagt
marita werden das sei nicht 24 stunden
mal
tasten drinnen nehme ich halt mich lieb
nein das ist kein dieb hatte sich jetzt
schön glühwein seien die wollen auch
ihre innere maximale rausholen ja okay
ich glaub bisschen aufgerüstet und
ausgestattet also das freilich will
heute auch kekse backen vielleicht
kriege ich ein bisschen inspiration und
ich musste heute auch noch blocken
das ding ist aber kennt ihr das beim
backen wenn man so und ball an kicks
teig gemacht hat und dann so ich sag mal
so zwei bleche in den ofen geschoben hat
das packen dauert ja gar nicht so lange
aber immer schon so nach dem zweiten
blech hab ich kein bock mehr
also dann hat man meistens noch so den
halben tag und stehe da irgendwie vorher
denkt sich jetzt auch mal zwei bleche so
am anfang ist das alles witzig und das
dekorieren am ende macht auch wieder
spaß aber irgendwie so zwischen dem
backen denkst oh nee ich hab halt auch
die backzeit so du machst du einen blech
und 18 uhr wieder aufgenommen so alles
so abschütteln so keiner weiß wie das
wirklich so am besten funktioniert aber
jeder schule dann irgendwie die kekse da
wir runter dann klatscht man auf dieses
heiße backblech wieder diesen neuen keks
teig dann schmilzt der schon an der
seite soll entlang und dann schiebst du
das wieder schnell rein also ist die
zweite ladung schon so ein bisschen
älter und ja die waren es 24 stunden
machen alles dabei
das haben wir vergessen heute
deco ganz super von meinen clips wie
sterne und blitze und marshmallows buch
das war doch ganz behalten wir haben
sogar noch zweimal zückt ich meinen
youtuber sind manchmal genauso wie in
ihren videos wenn man sie kennen lernt
also es gibt ein paar youtuber die hab
ich kenne ja die waren halt exakt wie in
ihren videos unter druck und man bei
manchen merkt so ok im video sind sie so
eine video person von sich was aber
nicht bedeutet dass sie sich verstellen
und irgendwie eine show abziehen
für irgendeine seite aber ich frage mich
ob bei den wirklich so manchmal oder
sobald die kamera ausgeht die sich dahin
setzen
ich meine so ein moderator für kids der
muss ja auch ne show also der macht ja
und kinder
und jetzt kommt das kikaninchen das ist
nicht so toll aber gekippt und so reden
ja auch ich frag mich auch die
eigentlich wenn dann wird es mit den so
also ob man mit den einen saufen
das ist meine frage derart vielen dank
das bier ist papa ich hab ich ja panik
ok ja ich will einfach nur wissen sie es
geschafft haben
also ich mach dir da bist du mich was
ich bin ganz happy mit dem bitte bitte
bitte bitte bitte ich frage mich bei
diesem ganzen leuten jetzt dieses iphone
11 haben war zufälligerweise dein iphone
10 kaputt weil die haben ja vor dass
eine von zehn gehabt und ich hab das
iphone 10
und ich habe nicht zu einer sekunde
gedacht mit das iphone 11 zu holen
also ich könnte nicht mal wenn ich das
bezahlen kann also ich könnte mein altes
land nicht oder so geben aber das doch
irgendwie komisch dass man sich wirklich
mal das neue handy holte ich muss gerade
irgendwie alles guten lehrern
das sind ausprobieren sie machen vor die
komplizierten keks ich dachte die machen
so sehr durch nico bin ich schön mal
wieder aber die haare offen im regal
verstauben sondern wird vor dem zimmer
eine kerze leben schon gemacht habe ok
ich will etwas kontroverses ansprechen
seit die rallye dafür haben die beide
aufgespritzte lippen
und ganz ehrlich es soll nicht sharing
sein dass die können sich eine dritte
nase operieren aber dass ich freue mich
dass immer weil ich das nicht so gut
erkennen kann ich will einfach für mich
wissen zweier nur genau das ist doch das
ist doch diese diese kurve kriegt man
doch nur wenn man sich die auf spritzen
lässt oder investigativer journalismus
ist jetzt ob die spritzen sind bis hin
zu viel wissen zu wenig wir können also
bei sarina er glaubt man das schon
und vielleicht auch ein bisschen die
ja wir haben also ich über die während
wir werden
ich bin 80 ja die fesche lola gekauft
zum back nimmt man eigentlich find
passierte wir haben natur ein und auch
das weckt am ende aber eben nur ein kind
haben sie jetzt angeschafft
den bezug auf die verschiedenen leben
dieses zeigt den gab es jetzt schon vorn
würde da lösen oder so also von einem
investor typ smith die werbung eingebaut
und hier schöner ist das ist auffällig
dass ist damit der zuschauer kämpfen
hält dagegen über ihr eigenes produkt da
muss man schon check dass es werbung ist
das nicht schön aber kontaktlinsen trägt
sie oder das sind ja nicht ihre echten
augen
ich möchte mal ich möchte ich sie möchte
ich mal richtig ungeschminkt einfach so
so oder andere sachen die man muss aber
schon sagen da spricht also ganz ehrlich
da spricht eher neid die haben absolut
mit ihrem springen eine pfütze haben die
richtig da mir richtig verdient haben
sicher die haben sich halt gut die kids
ab so dass
wer ist der teig wenn der kamera die
börse ist und ein schöner knödel
das problem ist nur den ganzen tag auf
essen oder kids machen
ich habe dir gleich zeit steht auf der
packung drauf 30 milliliter wasser
ach der keks teig zum löffeln dass der
ist gar nicht da drin und dann legt man
den einfach mal muss sie noch selber
machen
das service pack ich dachte man macht
das ding auf und frisst an diesem tag
raus und muss nicht erst da und jetzt
werden wir gleich zeigen von marie
oder wie wasser butter und acht tagen
den kick zum löffeln kann man auch die
zeigen die fertigen pixelig du musst
einfach ans ende gehen
[Musik]
was zur ist clever shuttle
da ist noch zu machen es ist mein neuer
traumberuf professioneller keks
becker-hecht doch keinen keks bäckerei
wer ist sie was ist denn das rosa loy
die werbe freundlichkeit ja bitte noch
etwas aufdringlich untergrund diesen
wirklich keine professionellen keks
becker das kann man sagen es geht
eigentlich mit meinem lässt
ich musste mein gesicht musste ich hier
sein damit es schön aussieht
[Musik]
das sind einfach zwar im besten freunde
lieber sitzend und kekse dekorieren 24
stunden haben wir wollen sich gemeinsam
mit euch verkosten und eigentlich haben
wir auch schon gar nicht mehr so viel
los aber es muss weiter gehen weiter
weiter weiter erhalten wie die ganz
normal
[Musik]
die sehen gar nicht gut aus also wenn
man keks zeigt zum löffeln hat und den
man so essen kann dann braucht man nicht
mit dem backen umweltbildung unter einer
gibt also kinder
wir haben euch zwar verschiedene zutaten
und gerichte gezeigt aber am ende hat
unserem besten funktioniert keine ahnung
warum
ja gut wenn du es ja so ein produkt das
gebe ich den so ein produkt auf die
beine zu stellen
also da hat bestimmt deren manager viele
von hell bis dunkel ist aber nicht 24
stunden vermählt dunkel zu hell ist
schuldig stunden
aber keine gehört dazu das kürzen
geschmack die ränder die will ich ein
bisschen verbrannt aber der kamera sind
das schmerzlich schwer krank
die frage ist jetzt was 24 stange
ausgehalten zwischendrin werden wir auch
mal den geschirrspüler an machen jetzt
richtig lecker dann eingeschlafen
es ist zwar 21 uhr ab jetzt kann doch
jetzt nicht hier schaffen wir haben
einen auftrag zu erfüllen aufwecken
hunger schlafen lassen
[Musik]
für diesen fall haben nicht frage sag
ich habe mir fertige lied guten kekse
besorgt die wäre jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen schön kapieren und dann sage
ich das ist das erste mal dass ich
wirklich diesen satz bruder muss los
fühle mich jetzt echt noch das
funktioniert das bei kindern das wollen
kinder
ich meine man muss immer sagen wenn ich
eine elfjährige tochter hätte würde ich
ihr kein youtube erlauben
ich würde ihr wahrscheinlich aber eher
das schauen lassen als wird mich oder
unsympathisch oder keine ahnung
es gibt hier wenigstens zu zunächst
heute einfach mal aus wie gekauft die
spekulation ist kreativ nur ich gut
machen können
der therapeutische effekt aus und wissen
dass wir für formen zuerst besitze ich
nicht gut schmecken
mutterstadt vielleicht ist mir sind
verziert
die haben zwölf stunden von 11 bis 11
dass meine freunde ist krieg hier haben
wir den klaren blick geht es ist geht
nämlich bei klick wert nicht darum einen
titel interessant also wenn du einen
titel interessanter macht aber er
trotzdem genau das beinhaltet was im
video passiert dann ist es okay aber
wenn du schreibst 24 stunden das ist
einfach faktisch falsch wenn man kann
auch freibier backen einen halben tag
lang weißt du was ich meine einer sein
wann sind wir 3400 zuschauer geworden so
ich brauche jetzt braucht ein gutes
weihnachtslieder samy slimani aber schön
dass man bei weihnachten dann ich habe
endlich für weihnachten geschmückt
sos geschenke sind dass diese sind dass
diese fachkräfte dieses superschnellen
will unesco diese sind auf ruft hallo
ihr lieben ich kann euch gar nicht sagen
wie begeistert ich darüber bin viele mir
in den letzten tagen gefolgt sind 222
ich mich total dass euch das so gut
gefällt deswegen habe ich heute auch
noch ein letztes geschenk idee video für
euch nicht auch noch keinen den obwohl
doch wir machen da wenn ich werde dieses
jahr gestartet ist und nicht weil sie im
video passiert ich will dieses jahr
bilder malen mehr meine ich hab mir die
letzten jahre so viel gedanken gemacht
wer was kriegen sollte so viel geld
ausgegeben und habe dieser gesagt mach
ich mal für alle und bild das macht mir
spaß natürlich meine zeit um meine
lebensenergie rein und dann ja was das
an diesem tag aber sie hat doch nur
glühwein getestet was euch denn von
anita tack xms mäßig schauen also stolz
auf ihr lieber braucht sozusagen last
minute geschenke und dann fangen wir
auch gleich mal an
als erstes habe ich eine kugel gestaltet
ihr habt ja diese tier kugeln die ich
letztens schon gemacht habe so toll
gefunden dass ich jetzt noch mal eine
wahrnehmung sanken oder blättern
das ist eine total süße auf weswegen ist
das so als kleid bin sogar noch zwei
okay das ist cool aber das ist halt
ultra viel aber ich kann sicher ich habe
der schokolade verteilt und mit
zusätzlicher weiße schokolade in so
einen spritzbeutel gefüllt meint an
leute und amerika sowie süßigkeiten
diesem gerät serien kann und zum schluss
nur so einen kleinen streusel in
herzform aufgemacht und schon ist gerade
auch schon fertig wie gesagt denn nur
noch in stücke schneiden und gerade für
liebe menschen ist das eine richtig
süßes idee
braucht ihr dafür und dann geworden ist
sie meinen ist mit fünf oder je nachdem
wie groß dieses geschenk eben das ist
meter kohle tier so eine
pralinenschachtel erscheint ich bin will
das skript durch das richtig anfasst es
wirklich basteln wollte aber dann nimmt
sie so eine schachtel wenn ihr auch
nicht so viel geld ausgeben wollt habt
ihr auch das muss man dann passt das für
jede ich weiß nicht gibt es ja einen
präsidenten beschossen experten das ist
was ist das für eine schachtel
das ist eine lindsay habe ich ein
geldgeschenk und zwar könnt ihr dafür
ein dass lindner ja ja mit diesem winter
diese mit blauen gold papiere lehre
pralinenschachtel nehmen und ja hab dann
einfach angefangen diese ganzen scheine
dort irgendwie zu das ist viel geld
ausgeben wollt dann macht das zum
beispiel nur mit fünf oder je nachdem
ihr habe ich mir als erstes tim schuldt
und ist dass ich finds mega irgendwie
denkt die schachtel von außen dass
derjenige das nicht weiter verschenkt
wie gestalten wir nehmen jede jeder
dafür habe ich mir als erstes design für
zu retten habe ich mir noch in meiner
heimat das ist toll mit gebraucht eine
große diskussion wie man das nennt das
ein lesezeichen dass ein klassiker das
habe ich glaube ich jedes jahr als kind
verschenkt
alle jahre wieder gibt es dinge die
können wir nicht ändern
relativ ausleben bild in der mitte
farben ob wie knete an aber wenn ihr die
dann nass macht und hätte dusche kommt
das duschbad raus und ihr könnt euch
bussen aufschreiben oder man lehrer gut
das sind ja so richtige krasse aber kann
man kann man auf jeden fall treu ich
glaube die macht gute sachen und
aufnahmequalität weihnachten im kinder
und ihr kind so fühlt sich an eltern wie
wir
ich teste food neuheiten zu weihnachten
kras rgq und willkommen zu meinem
christmas schloss video 2019 also quasi
es gibt so viele youtuber die man von
dem man noch nie was gehört hat und dann
gibt es einfach schon die crew dazu guck
mal wenn die sind ja viel zu fanny
goalie joey muss ich bei eigentlich mal
wieder was retten
die plätze noch mal an die torte gedacht
die ich von jimmy gerettet habe die
dümmsten weihnacht spielzeuge im test
dummer junge back ganz alleine
ich muss mir jetzt parkett gebracht und
zwar ist es diesmal
ich würde sagen es geht mir wieder ganz
schnell denn mich kann es nur einen
geben
ich weiß leute wir haben heute etwas
ganz besonderes excuse me be cool war
das denn bitte finden ist es was vor ich
habe schon seit über zwei jahren
[Musik]
hätte man das jetzt auch sollte wir
haben heute etwas ganz besonderes worten
ich habe schon seit über zwei jahren
kein einziges video mehr von mir ganz
allein gedreht kommt mal meine der cdu
sahen das immer irgendjemand dabei
wir werden heute eine ganz besondere
sache banken und ich habe ehrlich gesagt
vergessen was es denn ich habe ein
gedächtnis wie ein mega wir backen heute
zusammen eine carrot cupcakes millimeter
mascarpone rezept mit ihm ganz geschafft
hubmann ist also ein cupcake ist ja ich
war aber keineswegs inspiration macht
jemand gute kekse ich habe keineswegs
zuzupacken
ich bin so blöd in meinem kochbuches
sorgen hier gesetzt ob ich nicht mein
kochbuch ist was ich selbst erstellt
habe also ich würde sagen bei 3769
zuschauer beenden wenn sie mal den
stream eineinhalb stunden stream ist
doch gut den kann man sich auf jeden
fall nicht danach nochmal anschauen denn
das ist viel zu lang ich finde es
eigentlich ganz cool morgen kommt wieder
ein blog ist aber so
zweimal die woche ist camerons fanny
oder muss aber auch was zu tun haben
vielleicht sollte ich das nächste mal
regiert hat ist seine freude war denn
ich will doch nicht eben leute ihr
checkt es nicht ich bin also mein plan
war es zu streamen damit wir über blogs
und weihnachten reden können und uns
über viktoria syrien und musste ich
machen können aber ich will nicht der
neue monte oder der neue uni werden also
oder braucht das land braucht das land
eine weibliche akt channel
ich stelle den stream live bitte ich
mache ja bitte schau mir wieso soll ich
dir mir das video schauen ihr wollt doch
nur den tee dann schaue ich mir das
video und dann wartet ihr handy an
meinen lippen zu jedem wort was ich
sagen soll ihr das wollt so extreme
zocken
zum glück nicht mehr machen hast du denn
bei einer eingeklemmten nein ich hab mir
da beide nicht eingecremt aber danke für
die erinnerung aus dem erbitte ich würde
mich über den stream freuen
was ist aus karin geworden okay leute
ist gut
achso weiblicher projekt channel ja
darauf reagierte habe sorge dass ein
bisschen langsam holte ich werde jetzt
kekse backen und ich werde
basic pitch butterkekse machen aber die
werden lag ich schmecke und die welt
ihren morgen in meinem blog mit sehen
also bitte schaltet ein
ich habe heute auch mein talent endlich
aufgestellt weil ich noch ein parasit
anbau im keller hat oder ihn gefunden
habe und das sieht ja alles morgen in
meinem blog um 17 uhr kommt der blog
online wie immer und ich freue mich und
ich habe mich sehr gefreut dass wir
heute alle da ward und ja wenn wir
weiter nochmal stream werden dann sag
ich euch auf jeden fall vorher bescheid
wahrscheinlich auf instagram also folgt
mir definitiv 4 auf instagram wenn ihr
wissen wollt nicht streamer weil er
benutzt oder stories ganz ehrlich bis
dann leute kurs auf die nuss und